talk about Instagram here's an Instagram
I back to Liam Schreiber on opening
night of his new play on Broadway he's
also known for playing a Los Angeles
tough guy a fixer on the hit series I
love this show
ray Donovan it's on Showtime which by
the way is a division of CBS the Tony
Award winner is now back on Broadway in
the revival of what is it mr. Treiber
liaison doncha rouge that's it he stars
as a playboy in 18th century France
challenge with corrupting a young woman
Wow before her wedding now this key
resembles the key to your bedroom door
which I happen to know is kept in your
mother's room on the mantelpiece tied
with a blue ribbon take it attach the
blue ribbon to it and put it in the
place of your bedroom key which will
then bring to me I'll be able to get a
copy cut within two hours I'll return
you the original
you can put it back in your mother's
room then I'll be able to collect your
letters and deliver dolls knees without
any further complications
oh dear Shriver here's officer Tony
award-winning actress Janet McTeer in
the story of sex power
oh and big-time betrayal he joins us at
the table welcome back to you so I went
yesterday in the pouring rain just to
see you this is what fascinated me about
the play it's the dialogue let me just
give you a couple lines you given me
great pleasure but I just can't bring
myself to regret leaving you let's say
it's a little more acting I'm sorry I
want her to believe in God in virtue and
still not be able to stop herself you
only flirt with those you intend to
refuse I know it I love the language of
the flame you are such a cat in this
play though Lee Ann thank you I think so
is it something it's clearly not hard
for you to play because you play him so
well it's about sex and revenge
Imagineer play is it very hard
I didn't think it would be but it's
really really high well I think it's a
complicated place beast of a play um a
lot of dialogue particularly for Valmont
but I think the sexual indiscretion part
of it and the scandal of it is is really
complicated I think it starts out very
funny and it goes to some relatively
dark places yeah but I read you you
didn't think you were really right for
this part no I still thought you
but I'm really enjoying look that's part
of I think my job as an actors try to do
things that push me in different
directions yeah and I think you know one
of the things about doing something like
Rey which I love doing is that it's a
very specific thing and you on a
television show you end up doing that
for a long time so then you're sort of
looking for ways to expand yeah your
work and and your range and for me this
felt like it might be that kind of
opportunity yeah I mean ray Donovan
you've gotten such a following so many
people love love love that show and it's
now fifth season right going into yes
yes we're going into our fifth season so
why did you need more on your plate yeah
I didn't eat up that's a really good
point or is it see number one you have a
lot of dialogue
it seems grueling I went it doesn't seem
like you could ever zone out while
you're up there thinking what am I gonna
do for dinner I'll tell you what I did I
I wanted to be close to the kids I want
to pick a job that would put me in New
York and keep me in New York yeah and um
this was a job that was in the city and
it kept me around the kids top earners
to some ages on seven and nine sashenka
mm-hmm the problem is is that you have
no time to be with them on a theater
schedule but the last time yesterday
Wednesday matinee you had you did you
did five hours of theater two chairs
just this past Thanksgiving we had
Thanksgiving Day Off and then we did
five shows in two days Wow that's gotta
be exhausting I think the play is it's
getting rave reviews it's from the movie
there was a movie I remember the movie
years ago I remember the other play that
was on Broadway but now the time is so
different there's a scene that really
made me squirm and I'm wondering how you
feel about this he's seducing a young
girl yeah and half the audience we don't
know whether to laugh whether to because
it's very graphic number one and I
almost felt like I was watching child
molestation but people were laughing
does it make you uncomfortable am i
reading it wrong or right overthinking
it posed to make you uncomfortable I
think that's the clothes intention is um
look low who wrote this blatant during
the ancien régime and
in France wrote this play as a
cautionary tale to young girls and you
know sort of since been interpreted
particularly by the movie it's a sort of
wonderful sex scandal you know but the
reality is that the guy was writing it
to say watch out right and and so I
think the intention is that people
become very uncomfortable not seen now
of course
casting an actor of looks as old as me
and an actress who looks as young as a
winner
she looks beautiful yeah yeah she looks
a little bit yeah a little extreme but I
think that was the intention okay
that's certainly what women went through
in that period and I think that's
Josie's intention the picture on the
playbill with you here I mean wow that
one I like I mean that understand you
two had just met when you took that
picture yeah but she you got acquainted
very quickly yeah I mean that's Amy yeah
you got a quintic you got acquaintance I
asked you about the film you're working
on that you're co-producing called the
bleeder yeah which is about Chuck Wepner
right the boxer yes what Mohammed Ali
yes and you are you going through
intensive training for this where do you
know it's done we finished it we had at
the Venice Film Festival did really well
we had a Toronto did well there too and
she'll be coming out in the spring um
it's the story of the real rocky um yeah
guy there's right a model for Ron and
he's a wonderful character and it was a
lot of fun to do and Naomi and I got to
work together on it and I co-wrote and
co-produced it and I'm really proud of
it Philippe filardo a wonderful French
Canadian director are you and Naomi a
good place I have to say I was very
disappointed when I heard the two of you
had separated did she wrote in People
magazine that change is very scary but
you two seem to have navigated raising
your children together is change scary
for you
yeah of course it is mm-hmm but you know
we're parents together
yeah the will be together for the rest
of our lives no matter what and um we're
very close yeah I'm glad to hear that
hopefully that that never changes and I
don't think it will would you like me to
set you up with someone or you yeah okay
okay busy with the 15 years I got shrugs
no I'm here to help here to help it's
always good to see you
Congrats Thanks
Liev Schreiber thanks for being here you
can see lately liaison downs aru's on
Broadway at the booth theater now until
Jin really okay with that how did he do
how did he not as good as all yet
daughter Contras Oh